à 25 ans crystal goacolou est en poste à
la blanchisserie au sein de
l'établissement et service d'aidé par le
travail de la marsa 22 trappe du lavage
au séchage les vêtements proviennent de
plusieurs clients comme les agents de la
mairie de trappes ce jour-là cristal et
au repassage depuis 2013 elle se
professionnalise sur ce métier
j'espère une validation des compétences
sans métier que j'aime bien avec
je vis de progresser comme faire un
stage en milieu ordinaire reçu de son
côté andreas luca 33 ans travaille au
pôle sous traitance aujourd'hui il
scotche des cadres sur des photos
vendues ensuite dans des musées mais son
projet professionnel c'est
l'informatique qui avait plein de taille
ni dans la maintenance informatique
alors qu'1 que veut évoluer dans le
milieu de l'informatique et de la
maintenance les adh de trappes accueil
qu 145 travailleurs en situation de
handicap
ils ont des postes adaptés dans quatre
pôles d'activité blanchisserie sous
traitance espaces verts et restauration
un accompagnement au quotidien par 40
professionnels dont 25 moniteurs
d'atelier l'objectif de notre
établissement c'est de contribuer à leur
pleine inclusion sociale comme n'importe
quel citoyen en ayant la possibilité de
travailler donc avoir une rémunération
et d'être autonome de ce point de vue là
est également un accompagnement
médico-social
le vendredi 27 septembre prochain les
adh de la marsa vin organise une journée
portes ouvertes l'occasion d'une
cérémonie de remise des médailles
d'honneur au travail pour 30
travailleurs de cet établissement